>>> REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO VOTED TO PEACH
DONALD TRUMP ARE FACING PRIMARY
CHALLENGERS SUPPORTED BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
FOR THE RECORD, SOME SAY THOSE
CHALLENGERS ARE ALSO GETTING
HELP FROM DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS PETER MEIER, A
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM A
DISTRICT IN MICHIGAN DEMOCRATS
HAVE NOT WON SINCE 1990.
HE WAS CHALLENGED THIS WEEK BY
FORMER TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL JOHN GIBBS.
GIBBS IS ALSO AN ELECTION
DENIER.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE DONALD TRUMP
SHOULD STILL BE IN OFFICE?
>> I DO, YES.
HE SHOULD HAVE WON THE ELECTION.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE WON THE
ELECTION?
>> I DO, CRES.
>> GIBBS WON BY FEWER THAN 4,000
VOTES.
HE SPENT $334,000 OF HIS
CAMPAIGN, BUT THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE
OR DCCC SPENT 435,000 BOOSTING
GIBBS TIES TO DONALD TRUMP AND
THEY EVEN CREATED A TELEVISION
AD.
>> JOHN GIBBS IS TOO
CONSERVATIVE FOR WEST MICHIGAN.
HAND PICKED BY TRUMP TO RUN FOR
CONGRESS GIBBS CALLED TRUMP, THE
GREATEST PRESIDENT, AND WORKED
IN TRUMP'S ADMINISTRATION WITH
BEN CARSON.
GIBBS HAS PROMISED TO PUSH THAT
SAME CONSERVATIVE AGENDA IN
CONGRESS, A HARD LINE AGAINST
IMMIGRANTS AT THE BORDER AND
SO-CALLED PATRIOTIC EDUCATION IN
OUR SCHOOLS.
THE GIBBS-TRUMP AGENDA IS TOO
CONSERVATIVE FOR WEST MICHIGAN.
DCCC IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CONTENT OF THIS ADVERTISING.
>> SOME ANALYSTS SAY THAT AD
ACTUALLY HELPED GIBBS WITH SOME
REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
THAT'S BECAUSE IT ADVERTISES THE
CANDICE'S SUPPORT FOR TRUMP
WHICH COULD ENCOURAGE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TO SHOW UP AT THE
PRIMARY.
AND GIBBS IS NOT THE ONLY
ELECTION DENIER GETTING HELP
FROM DEMOCRATS.
THE TRANSPARENCY GROUP OPEN
SECRET SAYS DEMOCRATICALLY
ALIGNED GROUPS AND NONPROFITS
SPENT NEARLY $44 MILLION ON
REPUBLICAN RACES IN SEVERAL
STATES.
SO WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
WELL, THE THINKING IS THAT MORE
EXTREME REPUBLICANS WILL BE
EASIER FOR DEMOCRATS TO BEAT IN
NOVEMBER, BUT WHAT IF THEY'RE
WRONG?
HERE'S WHAT REPUBLICAN ADAM
KINZINGER TOLD CNN ABOUT THE
STRATEGY.
>> IF PETERS OPPONENT WINS AND
GAUNZ ON IN NOVEMBER TO WIN THE
DEMOCRATS OWN THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
HERE'S THE THING.
DON'T KEEP COMING TO ME ASKING
WHERE ARE ALL THE GOOD
REPUBLICANS THAT DEFEND
DEMOCRACY AND THEN TAKE YOUR
DONORS MONEY AND SPEND HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR MOTING ONE
OF THE WORST ELECTION DENIERS
THAT'S OUT THERE.
>> MEANWHILE A GROUP OF 35
FORMER DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS
ISSUED THIS JOINT STATEMENT
AGAINST SUPPORTING ELECTION
DENIERS.
QUOTE, THESE DESTRUCTIVE PRIMARY
TACTICS AIM TO ELEVATE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES WHO
DEMOCRATS HOPE THAT THEY CAN
MORE EASILY BEAT IN NOVEMBER,
BUT IT IS RISKY AND UNETHICAL TO
PROMOTE ANY CANDIDATE WHOSE
CAMPAIGN IS BASED ON ERODING
TRUST IN OUR ELECTIONS.
WE MUST STOP THIS PRACTICE AND
STOP TODAY.
NOW, THE DCCC SAYS ITS ACTIONS
ARE JUSTIFIED BECAUSE HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
IS, QUOTE, AN ANTI-CHOICE
INSURRECTION CODDLER AND ENABLER
AND WE WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO KEEP THE SPEAKER'S GAVEL OUT
OF HIS HANDS.
BUT IN JANUARY 2021 RIGHT AFTER
THE HOUSE VOTED TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP THE HEAD
OF THE DCCC CONGRESSMAN SEAN
PATRICK MALONEY, SAID THIS TO
CNN.
>> WE'VE DONE OUR DUTY IN THE
HOUSE, AND I'M PROUD OF THAT.
I'M PROUD WE HAD SOME
REPUBLICANS STAND WITH US, BUT
WE HAD FAR TOO MANY REPUBLICANS
IN THE HOUSE WHO HAVE AIDED AND
ABETTED THIS DISASTER, AND THEY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
IT'S NO SMALL THING TO SPREAD A
LIE THAT AN ELECTION WAS STOLEN,
TO MAKE IT SEEM AS THOUGH
THERE'S A MONSTROUS EVIL BEING
DONE WHEN IN FACT IT'S OUR
PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER.
>> DID YOU HEAR THAT?
HE SAID HE WAS PROUD OF
REPUBLICANS LIKE PETER MEIER WHO
VOTED TO IMPEACH.
FOR THE RECORD MEIER WHO JUST
GOT PRIMARIED TOOK AWAY A
DIFFERENT MESSAGE THIS WEEK.
>> I'M NOT HERE TO WINE ABOUT
THE DCCC COMING IN AND MEDDLING.
ANY PARTY THAT PRETENDS TO HAVE
A SET OF PRINCIPLES, PRETENDS TO
HAVE A SET OF VALUES AND COMES
IN AND BOOSTS EXACTLY THE SAME
TYPE OF CANDIDATE THEY CLAIM IS
A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY, DON'T
EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO HOLD ONTO
THAT SENSE OF SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS
AND SANCTIMONY.
DON'T EXPECT TO HAVE REPUBLICANS
WHO WILL LOOK AT THAT AND SAY I
KNOW I'M GOING TO GET HE